have you ever played a game that is so
good that you just have to upload it on
YouTube well let me tell you this is not
that game but we're gonna play it anyway
this game is called tricky truck it's
about having a tricky truck I know
you're dying to see me play more so
let's do this here we go
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
what is this [ __ ] how is it enough
are you [ __ ] kidding me ah what's
with the camera angles
ah alright well that was really fun
let's try another level shall we
Hot Wheels oh my [ __ ] god
are you [ __ ] me alright alright we
can do this we can do this come on Bruce
hundred percent now damn it
alright don't worry Bruce we got this
eye puck many cars in my days here we go
yeah no I'm fine I'm fine I can do it I
can still do it I can still do it
captain life is about living well ah
[ __ ] Jerry was driving that truck Jerry
it's okay man you should have seen the
look on your face Hey look at that
still going strong never mind
come on Jerry don't be a little [ __ ]
Jerry always told me don't be a little
[ __ ]
[ __ ] hell Jerry you suck so much this
is my chance now it's my chance
[ __ ] sake what is this truck made out of
Oh God okay
Oh God how is this even possible come on
go I'm gonna change the track we're
doing this one every go go Jerry Jerry
is the tennis ball of course
[ __ ] sake Jerry you piece of [ __ ]
there is such a little cut oh my god
what are you doing
this thing's steers like a [ __ ]
from hell when I [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
from there okay let's try this one it
doesn't even go straight come on back
ass
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] what yes bout the hell is
up for this car man let's change car
again there we go now this is how we
truck and Sweden [ __ ] we don't
we don't truck in Sweden [ __ ]
[ __ ] out the map broke Oh God
there's a will there is a way and I
definitely don't want to dammit
I swore to my parents that I would
complete this [ __ ] yes yes yeah
in each camp this truck is filled with
double-headed dildos for the lesbian
Club we got a hurry there hm
I don't know why I said it like god
[ __ ] dammit I hate my job
Aaron there we go there we go yes yes
I'm a truck driver I'm a truck driver
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god we're
left I repeat where the lab drinking
truck tree gate park that [ __ ] [ __ ]
sake
the [ __ ] is going on they're shooting at
me
[ __ ] hell nothing nothing is gonna
stop me from delivering okay maybe that
mission impossible great
what the [ __ ]
all right we need some more speed here
we go
what this [ __ ] I never appreciated how
hard it is to be a trucker
especially if you're a little bit
[ __ ] out ha ha here we got me [ __ ]
all y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] so close I don't
care I'm gonna keep going
or not this is for my homeland this is
for Sweden this is for this is for my
homeland nice is for Sweden but most
importantly [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
this is for Sweden this is for I care
this is for for God [ __ ] mother dick
in the ass for meatball [ __ ] May mom
100%
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
look at that face no Burnie the beer
alright what the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
oh god oh god oh god
reverse that [ __ ] help help oh no oh no
not out app app reverse reverse
someone please talk about a cliffhanger
Jesus Christ
Oh God Oh No Oh
here we got brass maximum speed Oh God
it was hard like what what is hard
Oh God are you [ __ ] kidding me
all right all right Matthew McConaughey
is it trick driven [ __ ] hell okay all
right
holy [ __ ] I'm a boss look at this [ __ ]
stay focused oh god oh god oh god oh god
we got to make it to the top come on man
you can't do that [ __ ] on me alright
alright alright hope you guys enjoyed
this video she did drop a like is that
helps to channel out and leave a comment
about Matthew McConaughey and how much
you want to make out with him but I mean
that's all for me for now thank you so
much for watching and as always stay
awesome press you're becoming more like
your father
oh okay we're good
stabilized